[Musique]
bonjour à tous bon là je viens d'être
comparé à dieu tout de suite ça met une
pression assez conséquente donc le
miraculeux dans le coma pour expliquer
donc ce processus à ce titre assez
énigmatique
je vais donc vous parler du processus
créatif du néant à la matière donc comme
il vous a quand il vous l'a dit je suis
sculpteur joaillier effectivement ce
thème par maîtres spécialement destiné
mon quotidien et de travail et des
matériaux exceptionnel brut souvent très
précieuse et imaginé à partir d'idées de
désir abstrait des pièces abouti
pratique est extrêmement raffiné
au début il n'y a rien j'avais dire
avant le big bang puis quelque chose
d'abstrait ce profil une idée un
sentiment un processus mathématiques
paraît-il dans le cas de la création de
l'univers et ensuite à une énergie se
dégage et mais la matière en mouvement
la faisant ainsi évoluer cela crée une
création qui a du sens pourrait-on dire
une fois en crochet ce processus ne
s'arrête jamais gagnant toujours plus en
complexité et en subtilité du plus petit
au plus grand on voit ce processus
exponentielle de la matière un petit peu
à l'image des fractales
alors évidemment rapporté à notre vie
commune d'humains cela pas cela peut
paraître abstrait et c'est pour ça que
l'illustré avec un métier manuel
il est intrinsèquement créatif permet de
le rendre plus abordable
comme je vous disais au début il n'y a
rien rien si ce n'est de ce désir de
créer en général cela vient d'une
insatisfaction de ce que l'on a
ou plutôt de ce que l'on n'a pas cela
couplé un mimétisme de ce que l'on
admire qui poussent à répéter à
améliorer et à améliorer la chose dans
mon cas j'ai toujours admiré les pièces
d'art la joie est baigné du rêve
enfantin de la notion de trésors le
voyage et l'architecturé temps mais deux
principales passions je me suis mis à
dessiner imagine et crée donc des des
plans de maisons de bateaux et réalisé
aussi des sculptures et pièces de
joaillerie faisant référence au voyage
que cela soit au tour du monde ou à
travers l'histoire
vous pourriez dire que tout cela c'est
bien sympathique mais c'est la lubie
d'un créatif et que ça n'est ni
merveilleux ni même comme à chacun
peut-être en fait c'est avec la notion
de rapport à l'autre que cela le devient
vraiment à quoi de plus commun que de
devoir satisfaire un client
nous sommes actuellement dans une
business school je pense que vous
comprenez parfaitement cela est donc si
vous y réfléchissez si vous y
réfléchissez il ya aussi quelque chose
de ma quasi miraculeux à réussir à
capter le désir profond d'un client qui
bien souvent ne sais même pas ce qu'il
veut vraiment comment fait on on écoute
on observe ces paroles sa gestuelle tout
une quantité de détails qui donnent de
l'information et que d'une manière
consciente ou inconsciente
on va utiliser pour se faire une image
mentale du projet les clients sont
souvent surpris que je retrouve une idée
en temps réel dès le premier entretien
mais en fait mais si le feeling passe si
bien c'est avant tout grâce à leur
capacité à communiquer ma propre
capacité à trouver l'image ne vient
qu'ensuite j'évoque la les clients
particuliers parce que le quand je vous
disais enfin comme il disait le gros de
mon travail c'est de la sous traitance
pour des grands noms du luxe ou bout des
commandes spéciales pour des familles
royales ou grosses fortunes
donc comme je disais lors de l'entretien
je laisse le client s'exprimer librement
pointant juste de ci de là des notions
comme ses goûts et intérêts et aussi des
choses essentielles comme le confort et
le budget ce dernier point est
d'ailleurs placée assez rapidement afin
de viser au plus juste dans ma recherche
créative c'est bien là un avantage du
sur mesure que de pouvoir proposer des
pièces en fonction des goûts et des
moyens réels du client
cela évite à toute frustration ou perdre
de temps disons que pour que le rapport
se fasse au mieux
j'aime à ce qu'ils soient abordés d'une
manière quasi amical d'abord c'est plus
agréable et ensuite ça permet une
communication plus fluide me permettant
de capter visiter les plus justes
c'est ainsi que pendant l'entretien je
fais donc des croquis devant le client
afin de montrer les idées au fur à
mesure qu'elles viennent le projet
choisi valider la matière entre enfants
d'action
en fait la fabrication est sans doute
l'étape la plus intéressante a évoqué
c'est le moment où ce syncrétisme le
plus concret et le plus abstrait en fait
avant de commencer à travailler la
matière
j'analyse mes dessins croquis et photos
afin de me faire une image mentale du
projet la pièce doit être parfaitement
établis dans mon esprit pour la suite
c'est c'est ce que j'appelle la vision
prod est en fait qu en jeu je pars de
mon blog de matières brutes
je vois la pièce à l'intérieur telle
qu'elle doit être
pour simplifier je n'ai jusqu'à découper
la matière qui dépassent pour la libérer
évidemment ça n'est pas aussi simple et
cela prend du temps passant par des
étapes de des gros sites forme
d'affinement de rapidement des détails
et alors ainsi toujours plus loin dans
la finition pour ce travail je peux le
faire dans de la cire pour les pièces
qui seront ensuite en métal via le
procédé de la fondation perdu dans de la
pierre dure ou précieuses cela peut
également être du bois la nacre ou même
du corail et dans ses travaux j'utilise
une multitude de petits outils des limes
des forêts des fraises certains de ces
outils sont d'ailleurs diamanté pour les
matériaux les plus durs il peut aussi
m'arriver d'avoir à souder des éléments
métaux précieux en fait avec les pièces
les plus complexes
on peut se retrouver aussi bloqué les
seuils de la difficulté que via un point
très intéressant que je dis violent que
je désire souligner c'est l'intuition
technique
chaque pièce étant différente des
problèmes à chaque fois nouveau se
présente également
on peut pas réellement reprendre une
solution d'une expérience passée à
chaque fois il faut
réinventer réadapter une technique
c'est pour moi l'intuition ce qu'il ya
de plus de plus merveilleux pour tout ce
que j'ai évoquées auparavant
l'observation l'analyse toutes ces
choses peuvent s'expliquer d'une manière
assez rationnel mais qu'en est-il de
l'intuition technique
j'ai pas vraiment de solution peut-être
comme toujours c'est l'observation de la
nature qui est la source de ces
nouvelles inspirations
c'est en créant que l'on devient un peu
un maillon un prolongement de la
création naturel c'est peut-être sous
cet aspect là que l'on pourrait dire que
l'homme a été fait à l'image du dieu
c'est dans sa capacité à créer et à
poursuivre ainsi le développement et
l'évolution
alors pour continuer avec quelque chose
de pur quotidien avait quelque chose de
plus concret personnel j'ai envie de
vous faire part de mon expérience la
plus directe et innocente du miraculeux
dans le coma je profite de par mon
métier de voir évoluer
qui plus est sous mes doigts des
matériaux bruts devenir de plus en plus
raffinés
j'apprécie chaque jour davantage
l'expérience de la matière de ma faculté
à pousser toujours plus loin dans la
richesse de pousser parfois ce métal
cette pierre où cette cire à sa dernière
limite physique juste avant que cela ne
casse le fondre une perdre on est là
en somme pour tout cela c'est un petit
peu comme jouer avec le feu le
perfectionnisme comme compagnon de jeu
compagnon qu'il faut parfois ne pas
suivre
ne disons pas le mieux est l'ennemi du
bien en fait c'est ses limites de la
matière nous rappelle à une certaine
humilité mais les contraintes créative
enfin pardon mais ces contraintes
physiques permettent le développement de
nouvelles idées créatives pour finir
avec quelque chose de plus abordable
j'avoue lui de vous montrer un peu en
guise de bonus
le clip d'une marque de fabrication
d'une marque de bijoux et accessoires
pour homme que je suis en train de
développer avec un ami
[Musique]
voilà donc c'était pour vous montrer que
s'il n'est pas indispensable d'avoir une
pièce d'exception pour pour être séduit
ou rêver je vous remercie de m'avoir
écouté et puis vu combien demandé
plusieurs fois la fin je ferai une
distribution de vivres ont versé
beaucoup
[Musique]